okay thank you in in your experience
is is islam innately misogynistic
the answer to that unfortunately is a
clear cut yes
okay islam is misogynistic in its
approach to women i know that by saying
this
i
offend a lot of people i know that
people's feelings get hurt the feelings
of muslims i know that that is the case
but setting feelings aside and just
looking objectively as what it is
that islam says about women
and
where it positions us
the answer is yes it is misogynistic
and i'll give you a few examples that
would be good yeah
and i think the best example
because it's so factual
is the law sharia law islamic law
islamic law declares
that a woman has to have a male guardian
at all times
that's not required of males
in sharia law a man is permitted to have
four wives
she's not permitted to have four
husbands
in islamic law in sharia law
a woman's testimony in court is worth
half
of that of a man it's not the other way
around
a sister inherits half of what her
brother inherits
wow
and
this goes on and on and i think to be
because these basic tenets of law
sharia law when they're implemented and
where they're implemented
you see a huge difference between the
way men and women are treated girls and
boys are treated and i would say that is
misogyny
and
because i'm not i'm not that familiar
with
islam is sharia law something that's in
the quran directly
sharia law is derived from the quran and
from the teachings of the prophet
muhammad the prophet muhammad is the
founder of islam
and his legacy is a body of law and
norms
that are implemented where there is a
theocracy like saudi arabia or iran or
any of the other societies that try
to establish
legal systems that are based on islam
so another example on the misogyny side
is
women are expected
to cover their bodies and there is some
kind of discussion on how much of that
in some cases they let you show their
face and the hands
and in extreme cases you have to be
covered from head to toe
and confined to the house
your male guardian
chooses or at least you need his
endorsements to marry someone else and
all of this
is
in uh based in sharia law if you're a
woman and you're not happy in a marriage
it's almost difficult almost impossible
to divorce your husband uh and
the other way around for a man to
divorce his wife all he has to say is
declare in front of two witnesses three
times that he divorces his wife and
that's done so
on the question is islam misogynistic
i think these facts speak for themselves
uh is islam inherently misogynistic
well first and foremost of course
there are misogyny needs to be defined
because if it's defined definitionally
as it is in the kind of dictionary the
hatred of women then the answer is very
clearly no because the quran very
clearly states
in more than one verse you know in
chapter three verse 195 in the la liga
god does not let to waste any action of
any doer among you men or women and that
both of you are from one another
that uh in chapter 33 verse 35
the believing men and the believing
women and the you know and so on and it
mentions
a list of attributes mentioning men and
women specifically and then says that
god has prepared for them a reward in
fact the quran explicitly mentions that
we cannot have hatred towards any
believer because it's mentioned in
chapter 59 of the quran
god do not put any hatred to the
believers in our hearts and that of
course includes women as well so from
that perspective it's impossible to
postulate it is
impossible to postulate that islam
is misogynistic from that definitional
perspective but what we will say is of
course misogyny is a label that is
used haphazardly and arbitrarily between
people in the west in discourses to mean
different things so of course
neoconservatives or people that are more
right-wing or alt-right are
accused themselves of being misogynistic
to uh by um third-wave feminists and so
on and so it really depends on who is
the one making the claim and what the
robust definition that they have of
misogyny is sometimes that can be
ideologically um
kind of inspired in the case of
third-wave feminists i would say it
certainly is that's why unfortunately
uh even your father has been accused of
misogyny i mean people in in in the west
uh credible intellectuals and academics
have been accused of misogyny just
because they believe in a traditional uh
value of traditional values of family
system a complementarian family system
and for this reason the accused of
misogyny but one has to say this and i
think this is very important michaela
that we believe that there is an
equality of value between men and women
we do believe that there is an equality
of value between men and women the
prophet himself muhammad he said
that certainly men are equal to women
in front of the law that is the general
rule that is a statement of the prophet
muhammad however
we do believe in exceptions and we don't
believe that equality of value means
identicality and roles
and so of course people that are
detractors from the other side
like the academic charlatan ayan mcgann
actually means refugee in the somali
language of course an ironic reminder to
herself
she would say that islam is misogynistic
because of practices such as polygyny
which means that a man can marry more
than one wife and that is a practice
that muslims believe in
all practices such as that muslim men
can marry christian and jewish women of
course that is something that muslim
women cannot do in islam as well
and various other inheritance things or
aspects where there is a differential
there between how men
are treated to women
but we will say that equality of value
does not mean identicality and roles let
me say that one more time equality of
value we believe does not mean
identicality and roles and therefore
just like aristotle said that like
things should be treated like likewise
and that different things should be
treated the same we do believe that
women have a collective female
temperament on certain aspects which
need to be tailored for in legislation
which need to be tailored for in social
and political life and so therefore if
someone wants to use second wave
feministic collectivistic discourses to
try and attack the islamic narrative
then they must first establish the
truthfulness and the objective the
objectiveness of second wave feministic
discourses iron hersey's a feminist we
are opposed to feminism when we say that
feminism has now
almost certainly been cracked open as a
false ideology of course i think what i
think i should add to this in addition
to all that was aforementioned that i
and mcgann herself
was embroiled
in the most embarrassing
of public inquiries if you can call that
that whereby she herself was in a
preligious relationship she was a
mistress
she was a mistress to niall ferguson her
husband now and she was doing so at the
dismay of sue douglas who is his ex-wife
and
with the destabilizing effects of course
the destabilizing effect to his family
to lachlan ferguson to phoenix ferguson
the children of nile ferguson
so she attacks poligini in her books but
she practices in her daily life
and so this is
a serious hypocrisy
not just
in that what she does mcgann iron mcgann
but in that which she states as well
so the challenge really is and i will
repeat this if someone wants to quote
aspects of the islamic discourse aspects
of the islamic
jewish prudential tradition
and juxtapose it with the western
discourses especially here we're talking
about second wave feminism and expect
islam to correspond with those they'll
be utterly and bitterly disappointed
because clearly we believe our system is
superior we believe the system is
failing we believe that
nuclear households are being destroyed
in the west we believe that you've got
it wrong we believe that we've got it
right and so in order to defeat us an
argument you must first argue from first
principles and so yes we do have
differences with western especially
second wave or third wave feministic
discourses but that does not
that does in no way
show show indicates
that islam is misogynistic to the
contrary and one last thing i will say
is megan herself
is blissfully ignorant ayan mcgann i and
hersey mcghan
blissfully ignorant of the islamic
tradition the
under-qualified over-confident
ultra-crepidarian academic charlatan
right-wing apple polish-up
obsequious woman that she is doesn't
even know
that it doesn't even know the basics of
the islamic tradition mentions in her
book heretic in page 77 that we worship
muhammad she doesn't even know the
basics of the religion she makes
squandering mistakes one after the other
about gender in jewish prudence in islam
in her latest book at pray you can see
in page 151
where she makes a series of
unsubstantiated claims about muslim
women and their rights in islam saying
that their rights can be sold to
strangers and all kinds of nonsense
propositions which have no basis in the
religion of islam so if you really want
to know about women's rights in islam
one has to go to the source and this
ultra crepidarian academic charlatan
ayan is is just a failure who's who's
been uh embroi has been
let in by the most unusual types of
affirmative action program to the
neoconservative circles because she has
no academic uh acumen at all